santander qui m'ont dit la famille
cassard aurait pu tout perdre et grâce à
la présence d'esprit des voisins leur
sang froid et l'arrivée rapide des
pompiers leur habitation a été sauvée
elle est intégrée au bâtiment d'où les
flammes sont parties le départ du ce a
eu lieu là il y avait deux les portes là
donc quelle est ta ferme et je les ai
vus on veut fermer
et puis l'origine du sinistre est autour
de ce tracteur le lendemain de
l'incendié des techniciens en
identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie sont venus sur place pour
tenter de relever des indices
on sait pas ce qui s'est passé on est
les grosses interrogations mais bon
sachant quand même qu'il y avait un
tracteur à l'intérieur on avait peur
mais bon on pense toujours que ça va
arriver chez les autres chez nous c'est
la série d'incendiés dans le secteur qui
inquiète les habitants
cela a commencé fin avril dans une
ancienne ferme
elle était très isolée au milieu de la
forêt tout ça je crois que c'était leur
première cela et puis après sera
voudrait flanc gauche
l'aurait il ya eu aussi les a servis à
chaque fois comme pour tout incendie une
enquête a été ouverte par le parquet de
besançon
cette proximité dans le temps et
l'espace intrigue les gendarmes
pour l'instant la piste criminelle n'est
qu'une hypothèse alors et deux incendies
ont eu lieu en pleine nuit dans deux
fermes à moins d'une demi-heure
d'intervalle
les gendarmes appellent les agriculteurs
à la vigilance